hey everyone today on the things we're
going to dive into maleficent's dark
fast we're going to uncover the truth
about her tortured history to see why
she became the most famous and feared
Disney villain of all time we first got
to know Maleficent from the Disney
classic animated film Sleeping Beauty
she was dark and sinister she had a
thirst for vengeance when she felt
double-cross she seemed like an evil
sorceress with a heart of stone it
wasn't until later that we learned that
there was much more to her than we first
believed as it turns out Maleficent
wasn't always evil she has a
heartbreaking backstory that would turn
even the sweetest virtuous person into a
bitter angry villain Maleficent grew up
as a fairy in the Moors she was
different from the other fairy as we've
read about in the storybooks
while most fairies have sparkly glitter
wings Maleficent had enormous raven
wings
she was always courageous and heroic
even when she was young not only did she
protect the Moors but she also led a
lost orphan boy named Steven back to the
human world Steven was wearing a ring
with the ability to burn fairies this
loving gesture made Maleficent fall
deeply in love with him so far
Maleficent doesn't sound like a villain
right well this next part definitely is
the key to where it all went bad for her
on Maleficent 16th birthday Steven gave
her what she believed to be a true
love's kiss but it wasn't Steven didn't
love her and after her birthday that
year he stopped coming to see her a
Steven a Maleficent grew older tension
between the human world and the fairy
world increased to the point of battle
Maleficent defeats the king so the king
tells his men to avenge him in order to
win the throne so clearly Steven would
never hurt the fairy girl who had been
so kind to him right
wrong Steven does the worst possible
thing you could do to a fairy he steals
her wings that was the last straw for
Maleficent
he used Maleficent to become King and
what's worse he didn't even care that he
had hurt her so deeply Steven married
the daughter of the former king and they
had a baby girl named Aurora aka
Sleeping Beauty of course Maleficent was
royally ticked off about the
whole thing so she cursed evens newborn
daughter she said that Aurora would fall
into a deathlike sleep
Stephen begged Maleficent to spare his
daughter's life so she said that
Sleeping Beauty can be awakened but only
by Stephen becomes super paranoid over
the next few years he's a man obsessed
and tries to hunt Maleficent down
he sends his men out to find and destroy
her but they do not succeed but with all
of this anger and Maleficent heart she
still has the capacity to love she met
little five-year-old Aurora after she
saved her from falling off a cliff she
starts to feel close to the girl before
she sends her away back home when Aurora
turns 15 years old
she does a lot of exploring in the
forest near the cottage where she's
staying
the soldiers nearly mistake Aurora for
Maleficent things could have gone very
bad for her if Maleficent had not
stepped in and saved her Aurora believes
Maleficent to be her fairy godmother
Maleficent invites Aurora to spend time
in the Moors
she even introduces her to other fairies
and magical forest creatures Olympus in
an Aurora form a mother-daughter type
bond over the next few months for a time
Olympus it becomes caring and nurturing
instead of vengeful since she loves
Aurora she tries to remove the curse
that was placed on her all those years
ago
unfortunately she can't because no power
on earth can lift it except for true
love's kiss Aurora wants to live with
Maleficent in the Moors so Maleficent
thought she might be safe from
encountering a spinning wheel but then
Aurora finds out that Maleficent is the
fairy who cursed her as a baby she runs
away back to her father's castle where
she encounters a spinning wheel and
falls into a deep sleep Maleficent tries
to get Philip to kiss Aurora and wake
her up he tries but the kiss has no
power
Maleficent out sleeping Aurora that she
got so lost in vengeance and hatred that
she forgot about love and joy Maleficent
swears to protect her just as Maleficent
is leaving Aurora awakens turns out
maleficent's love for Aurora broke the
curse hers was the kiss of true love
that broke the spell suddenly Stephen
soldiers show up they'd burned her with
an iron net she does her best to defend
herself and protect Aurora but Stephen
tortures Maleficent and teases her
because she no longer has her wings
right before he tries to end Maleficent
Aurora releases her wings which return
and reattach themselves to her back
Maleficent defeats the guards and
carries Stephen to a tower she wants to
hurt him but instead she decides to let
him go but Stephen refuses to let her
off the hook so he jumps on her back
they both fall from the tower but she
flies up while Stephen plummets to his
doom peace is finally realized between
the human and fairy world
Maleficent destroys the thorn barrier
around the Moors and gives her crown to
her Aurora this makes her queen of both
worlds Wow
Maleficent has been through so much her
story is complicated and full of tragedy
but also redemption the dark truth about
Maleficent's past is that love is both
her weakness and her strength she chose
to give her love to the wrong person
this made her suffer a great deal but if
she hadn't loved Stephen she would never
have met Aurora her motherly love for
Aurora allowed her to feel happy again
she had the courage to truly love
someone even after she was nearly
destroyed by her love for Steven it just
goes to show that true love doesn't just
exist between a prince and a princess
love can liberate even the darkest of
hurts some fairy tale can be downright
heartbreaking but we're glad that
Maleficent finally found love in the end
even misunderstood villains deserve true
happiness and love don't you think what
do you think about Maleficent's dark
past
is she evil nice or somewhere in the
middle let us know in the comments
section below and thanks for watching
the themes make sure to subscribe to be
the first to see our latest videos and
if you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up we'll see you soon
[Music]